- I'm competing with my job.
Often on the other side
of what you're afraid of,
that you experience really great things.
It's so hard to say no to stuff.
I think you always want
to be challenging yourself
and pushing yourself in
the work that you do,
because that's how you
experience those situations.
What's the impediment to
action advances action.
What stands in the way becomes the way.
I try to think about this in my own life.
- Hello, Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe
and I believe in people more
than they believe in themselves
and my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you,
you'll be able to change the planet.
So to help you in your journey,
today we're going to learn
from author, marketer,
and entrepreneur Ryan Holiday
and my take on his Top 10
Rules to Success, Volume II.
Rule number eight is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
Also, as you're watching,
if you hear something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around
it so that other people
can be inspired by it, as well.
And if you leave it within
the first couple hours
of this video going live,
you have a chance to win
one of two daily prizes.
(whooshing)
(empowering music)
- I would rather challenge
myself in my career
than challenge myself on a roller coaster,
which is totally pointless.
And I would rather,
like for instance, I love running.
I run almost every single day.
But I don't do any races.
I don't feel the need to
have artificial competition
in my life.
Like I'm competing with my job.
Do you know what I'm,
I'm trying to write the best,
I'm trying to challenge
myself with my writing.
Running for me is something that I enjoy.
And to me the challenge is
like can I do it every day?
Not like did I beat 200 other
people who I don't care about?
- Well, I think the point for,
the one thing you've
added is I think sometimes
we have these artificial
expectations that are unnecessary.
Right, you're like, "I run
because I enjoy running.
"I'm not trying to be competitive."
And for your writing, you are competitive,
but with yourself.
- I think being present
and enjoying what happened
is important.
But I guess what I'm saying
is like yesterday I ran.
I did an hour.
And it was, you know,
92, 93 degrees outside.
It was hot, right?
But I didn't say, like,
is this going to be enjoyable or not?
I said look, this is what do.
And come hell or high
water, I'm going to do it.
And it was enjoy, I got,
it wasn't enjoyable at first.
But I pushed through.
It's like on the other
side of that resistance
is often that thing.
And so I think that's
the problem with people
who are like, you know, "I'll
just sort of go with the flow.
"I'll take it as it happens."
That can work, but, you know,
it's often on the other side
of what you're afraid of
that you experience really great things.
And you have to have the
power to push through that.
What do you feel the most satisfied doing?
And what do you feel the
most sort of fulfilled
or creative doing?
And then that's going
to be the sort of gift
that you protect at all times.
And then you've got to
find the other things
that you're either good at,
but you don't want to be doing,
or you're really bad at,
that take a lot of your time.
And you've got to be able to
delegate and find services
or companies or other people
that you can hire to help
you with those things.
And like that's really,
that's always been something
that I've struggled with
that I think is a sort
of perennial struggle
of any kind of leadership
or entrepreneurship.
How do you,
how do you build the
organization or the structure
that you need so you can continue
to do what you need to do
as the boss or as the main creative force?
And you've got to be able
to continually evaluate
your own performance in
that sense and say like,
look, this is what I'm really good at.
This is what I'm not good at.
Here's someone who's better at it than me.
I'm considering it an
investment to hire that person
or to bring on that service provider.
And I'm doing is so that I
can continue to be as good
as I need to be at my
like sort of core thing.
It's 8 a.m., like I got
to get to the office.
And I was like why?
Why do I have to get?
I always wanted to be a writer.
I accomplished this thing.
I can make a living being a writer.
I have a home.
Like, I haven't been there in weeks.
Like, why am I here?
And I was like, I was here
because like I just said yes
and I didn't think about,
I didn't actually weigh the
pros and cons of this scenario.
And again, it's like
something you got to do
what you don't want to do to
figure out what you want to do.
But it was like,
I'd sort distanced myself
from a lot of things.
And I'd gotten my life in a good place.
And then someone called me and
offered me money on the phone
and I said yes.
Because it's so hard to say,
like it's so hard to,
to say no to stuff, especially
if you're like a doer.
It's so hard to say
like, I want to do this,
but I also want to do that.
I have to choose.
It's easy to say like, I'm
going to try to do both
at the same time.
And I said yes to both.
Like, I don't think I've
ever like quit anything.
Like I've just added new stuff.
And so for me that certainly
has added up over time
to an unsustainable load.
We all wake up the same.
Every day we both wake up
and things don't go the way we're,
like there's not just the
adversity when you're younger,
by there's also the day-to-day realities.
Like you run a business
and I run a business.
And, you know, this,
you have a problem with
your accounting software.
And then you're having problems
with Skype this morning.
There's also those minor situations.
And how you choose to
deal with them determines
whether you're going to have
a good day or a bad day,
just in the same way that
other situations determine
whether you're going to have
a good life or a bad life.
And how you choose to respond,
like if you,
you know, Skype wasn't working.
And if you said like, if you got mad,
if you decided this was horrible,
if you got really frustrated, it might,
not only would that
mess with your attitude,
but then,
it doesn't help you with the situation
that you then have to
deal with which is okay,
how am I going to find a solution
and how am I going to do this interview
and how am I going to
get the best out of it?
Like I'm giving a talk.
Let's say I'm giving a talk
in front of an audience.
I don't control the audience.
I don't control, you know,
the weather, I don't
control any of these things.
But I do control what I
bring to that situation.
So I want to focus the
entirety of my energy on doing
the best possible job and
salvaging the most out of it.
I think that the big problem
that many people have
is they don't know
what's important to them.
And so they end up getting
distracted by things
that other people are doing
or things that other people
are trying to do to them.
And so, like we were talking
about with my business,
early on, I'm thinking
okay, this is the way
you're supposed to do things,
because this is how everyone
else runs their business.
What I didn't stop to do was think
what kind of business do I want
and what kind of life am I trying to have?
And when I was actually able
to have that conversation,
I was able to cut out a
bunch of extraneous things.
It makes the most sense
for my personal happiness,
and my personal success to
try to make as much money
as possible for as least
amount of time commitment
as possible, so I can
write as much as possible,
versus trying to make as
much money as possible,
however possible, right?
And so, sometimes you've got
to do the wrong thing to,
like you got to touch
the stove and go like,
this is really hot.
I don't want to do this ever again.
And so I sort of pivoted my business.
And they say like it's not a principal
till it costs you money.
Like one of the other partners went off,
started a different company and has made,
you know, has done very well for himself.
And we've passed on a lot of projects
that went on to do pretty well.
So like, you see,
like, there's a cost.
So like having the life
you want, there's a cost.
And you got to be ready to pay that cost.
And the worst thing you
can do is try to have like,
try to have your cake and eat it, too,
like try to have the life you want
while doing the things you don't,
it just doesn't work.
I think you always want
to be challenging yourself
and pushing yourself in
the work that you do,
because that's how you
experience those situations.
You know, it's very easy once
you get to a certain point
to be, to sort of find your
comfort zone and stay in it
and not be challenged.
But that's not to say
that life won't visit
challenges upon you.
But you're going to
experience less, right?
But I think exercise and
working out is a great metaphor
for this, like I try to
run every single day.
And I don't care what the weather is.
I don't care how I'm feeling.
It's something that I'm
going to subject myself to
and force myself to.
And you know, often I'll find like,
I run in the afternoons, for instance.
And I'll find that I'll be tired,
that the day won't have gone very well.
That maybe I wasn't feeling great.
But that hour that I'm out there sweating,
when I come back, I'm ready to go again.
I've been recharged.
And I think being able to find
that hey, I do better when I'm challenged
is a great thing to teach yourself.
And the other thing,
Tim Ferris told me this,
he was saying, you know, if
you work out every single day,
you have a guaranteed
win every single day.
So your company might
be declaring bankruptcy,
but you set a new PR,
Or you got a great rush of endorphins,
you'll at least be able
to tell yourself like,
hey, that went well.
And that's something that I,
that the reason I seek out
that hardship every day
is that it's a hardship
that I'm sort of guaranteed to overcome.
As a creative,
what the critics think of your work,
what the audience thinks of your work,
what gatekeepers or lists, or,
you know, curators think of your work,
these are the things that
are outside of your control.
And you have to remind yourself of that.
And as a creative, if you
go into what you're doing
and you just say I'm
only going to be happy
if this external thing happens, right,
I'm only going to be
happy if it's published
by this publisher.
I'm only going to be happy
if it wins this award.
It's only going to make me happy
if make this amount of money.
These are recipes for misery,
because you've now put your happiness
in the hands of someone else,
someone who is indifferent to you,
someone you don't control.
You make a business decision,
I've done these myself.
You make a business decision or a choice
and it turns out to be a mistake.
You were totally wrong.
You can see that as a mistake
and you can get down on yourself,
or you can see it as a
chance to get comfortable
with failure, because
failure is a part of life.
Where a scientist doesn't get upset
when a hypothesis that they
had turns out to be wrong,
because that's what they do.
That's the whole point.
They're learning each time
they do something wrong.
Or a computer, I'm sure
as college students,
a lot of you get this, as well.
You spend weeks and
weeks working on a paper
and the computer deletes it.
A glitch erases the work that you've had.
So you can get upset.
You can deal with it.
What I did the last
time this happened to me
was you get so upset
that you kick a trash can
across the room and it makes
a huge dent in the wall.
Or you can see this as
a chance to start over.
You can see it as a chance to,
now that you've been through
it once, to do it again,
and ultimately produce a piece of work
that's of higher quality
than maybe you originally
intended to turn in.
You can use that as a chance, actually,
to raise your standard, rather
than simply muddle through.
What's the impediment to
action advances action.
What stands in the way becomes the way.
I try to think about this in my own life,
whenever I'm facing any kind of situation.
And I've yet to find one
that isn't made better
from this attitude, that isn't made better
by seeing each and every
obstacle as a chance
to practice excellence in its,
in a new form.
And you know, I think today,
we all face our own problems.
There's tough economic times.
We have a political situation that's uh.
We all face individual
obstacles as a daily basis
and we culturally face obstacles.
But we have a chance to see
those things like they saw them,
which is to not only not see them as bad,
but to see them as opportunities,
as chances to improve,
or to practice something
that perhaps we wouldn't
have otherwise practiced.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Garret D asked me to.
If there's someone
you'd like me to profile
in a future Top 10,
please check out the link
down in the description below,
and you can cast your vote
on who we should do next.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Dave Lukas
from the Misfit Entrepreneur.
Dave, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word and for taking
that awesome picture of you
with the book at the beach.
Makes me jealous, kind
of want to be there.
It makes really good beach reading.
So thank you so much for
the support and posting it.
And I'm so glad you enjoyed the book.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
(whooshing)
- Let's focus on what
benefits are inherent
in any situation.
And let's not focus on what
we've been deprived of.
Because we can't,
we control only that attitude, right?
And so we might as well give ourselves
the attitude that pushes us forward,
that makes us feel,
that seizes on what we
are empowered to do,
and not dwell on what
we've been deprived of,
or what is holding us back.
I do think it's interesting
how we sort of expect,
like, a few months ago, I got injured,
and I couldn't work out for
like about a week or so.
And it was like, why did
I think that I could go
my whole life without being,
like why did I think I would
never be injured, right?
Why did I think it would,
I would all, it would,
every time I would roll my ankle,
it would turn out to be nothing.
Do you know what I mean?
Sometimes it turns out to be something.
And the more we can,
the more we can tell
ourselves that these are
realities of life, the
less devastated we'll be
when they happen, and the
more quickly we can bounce
back from them, do you know what I mean?
Like if someone does something rude or,
you know, screwed up to you,
and you're like why did this happen?
This is so unfair, how
could they do this to me?
And all you're doing is
wallowing in self-pity,
you know, that's precious
energy that you're not spending
towards your, you know, your reply,
towards your response, or what
you're going to do instead.